[موسيقى]
تقلل اسرائيل من فداحه مصابها وتقول ان
قبتها الحديديه اعترضت اكثر من 90% من هذه
الصواريخ عند تحليل عمل القبه الحديديه
نجد انها تعتمد على جهاز الرادار الذي
يتتبع ويرصد الصواريخ المراد استهدافها
ومن ثم يرسل بيانات الصاروخ واتجاهه الى
وحدات التحكم بالاطلاق التي تحللها لتعطي
الاوامر الى قاذفه الصواريخ لاطلاق صاروخ
الاعتراض وتستطيع اعتراض صواريخه في مدى
70 كيل مترا وبحسب شركه رافائيل المصنعه
ال قبه الحديديه فانه عند محاذاه صاروخ
الاعتراض للصاروخ المستهدف فان الاول
ينفجر مطلقا مجموعه من الشظيه التي تتسبب
بتدمير الراس الحربي للصاروخ
المستهدف فعليا في الرؤوس الحربيه لصواريخ
القبه لا تحوي اي شضايا ويمكنك مشاهده ذلك
من خلال كاميرات السرعه العاليه فالذي
يخرج عباره عن نار ومواد بلاستيكيه لا
يوجد تاثير والموضوع عباره عن كذبه كبيره
فيما لو دفع مط القبه الحديديه الشايا نحو
صاروخ مدفعيه متهاون ولكن لا يدفع الشدا
نحو الراس الحربي الامامي فهو فقط يخرق
محرك الصاروخ الفارغ لان وقود الصاروخ
يكون قد استهلك ويمضي الصاروخ ويسقط على
الارض وينفجر بمعنى انه لم يتم اعتراضه
كيف يمكن الحسم بشان القبه الحديديه بين
اصرار اسرائيلي على فاعليتها بنسبه 90%
وشهادات لخبراء تتحدث عن محدود
هذه الفاعليه هناك عدد من الرشقات التي
ليس بامكانها ان تصل الى كل المناطق هناك
بعض الصواريخ التي لا يتم اعتراضها او لا
يتم اختيار اعتراضها كان نقول ان الفعاليه
تصل الى
65% لكن عندما نقوم بتفسير واضح في
المناطق التي يتم الدفاع بشانها فان 90%
ربما قد تكون نسبه منطقيه القبه الحديديه
اقول فشلت لجمله اسباب هناك نقاط ضعف
واضحه لا يستطيع اي انسان ان ينكرها القبه
الحديديه تتعامل مع 5 كيلومتر الى 70 يل
متر ماذا عن ما قبل وما بعد القدرات
الصاروخيه للفصائل تم اجراء تطوير عليها
بعده ابعاد ليس في بعد واحد اولا مدى
الصاروخ وزن راس الحرب
المتفجر زوايا الاقتراب وهذه نقطه قاتله
للقبه
[موسيقى]
الحديديه